le sénat ce que je veux dire c'est que
le résultat des élections sénatoriales
aura une conséquence majeure pour
équilibrer ce qui risque d'être
déséquilibré à partir du moment où il
n'y a pas la majorité des trois
cinquièmes
il ya un certain nombre de réformes
institutionnelles qui pourront ou pas
avoir lieu
et dans les réformes institutionnelles
qui sont envisagées eh bien je pense que
s'il n'y a pas les 3/5 ses réformes
institutionnelles il devra y renoncer
voilà donc pour vous le savez là l'enjeu
est là l'enjeu la droite l'enjeu quand
ils l ont fait la majorité des trois
cinquièmes il y aura pas de récit et
s'il y a s'il peut y avoir des infos
possibles à condition que ce soit de
bonne réforme
quand donc je dis donc l'enjeu tue à
résultats des élections sénatoriales
d'un enjeu majeur parce que 7,6 n'y a
pas et cette majorité 3/5 ça veut dire
qu'il n'ya pas de blanc seing qui est
donné à la nouvelle majorité au
président de la république donc c'est un
enjeu majeur